[Music]  another seven done you guys  ariana grande takes us to church on her  sexy new single God is a woman the 25  year old singer who got engaged to  comedian Pete Davidson in June is  showing off her pious promiscuity on the  new track which is full of clever  innuendos and straight-up good loving  godliness  [Music]  Ariana initially revealed the track in  May during an appearance on The Tonight  Show with Jimmy Fallon hilarious she  says her 92 year old grandma who she  calls Nonna has the sensual song on  repeat that's a favorite I'll ask her  like hey Nona what do you think of like  you know my single would it do you like  no tears have to cry and she's like I  love it me and no ireon oh can we listen  to God as a woman again  [Music]